[Music]
it blast for the past news submitted by
Michael Jackson or Joe Jackson all day
even I choose my job Michael Jackson
Michael job please bring Michael Jackson
back and just take login pawns for one
you take both applause this kit was
Michael Jackson yes [ __ ] that rich guy
[ __ ] that rich douchebag ah yes and his
[ __ ] tiny ass teeth its proper and
his pointed down nose an unexpected
letter allegedly written by an infamous
Alcatraz escape be has brought their
case back into the spotlight
whoa way escapee successfully escaped
yeah happy there's only been two people
in history that actually escaped
Alcatraz and nobody knows where they are
are they brothers or the brothers her
cousin abut then I didn't want come back
that's why there's two missing right not
one guy I thought one died but one used
to do the tours there what what better
like how never heard that I thought
there were brothers and cousins or
something so yeah there were a pair of
brothers and one of those brothers
claims to be the person that wrote this
letter oh yeah
so these are the guys it's too late to
put them back in jail so well it's gone
so [ __ ] this is Frank Morris this is
Clarence Anglin and then these two are
brothers Clarence and John England okay
and this is what they would look like oh
I thought this was actually dabbles
that's pretty yeah that's really good
yeah no so they did like a
computer-generated yeah how would they
choose what kind of hair that would have
I don't know how they know that they're
now beasts mmm more facial hair so this
is a guy that claims to have sent the
letter and so he said my name is John
Anglin I escaped from Alcatraz in June
1962 with my brother Clarence and Frank
Morris I'm 83 years old and in bad shape
I have cancer yes we all made it that
night book barely he goes on to say that
he lived in Seattle and then he moved to
North Dakota and then he eventually
settled in SoCal and so he real that's
what he's claiming about rumors
rumor had that they went to South
America well rumor had it that they all
just died and that the the Pacific Ocean
ended up getting their bodies or
something yeah sharks ate dinner [ __ ]
yeah so then he's also claiming that
Morris died in 2008 and that his brother
died in 2011
oh no he also writes if you announce on
TV that it will be promised to first go
to jail for no more than a year and get
medical attention and we'll write back
to you to let you know exactly where I
am this is no joke oh [ __ ]
this letter was sent to the San
Francisco Police Department's
Richmond station back in 2013 that's
pretty cool they examined the letter
back then into 2013 but they said that
the results were inconclusive inclusive
what if it's a troll it could be a job
that's why they never did like a hoax
well all you have to do is put his
fingerprint on the thing because they
should have this remember yeah but they
don't have the fingerprint technology
was in that great back then so they
probably don't even have a long record
they couldn't find anything like on the
actual letter well he's more like a DNA
yeah no DNA and then the handwriting
doesn't really match up to what it was
previously the records that they have
but it could have just been like from
old age I just shake it like a mother I
think inclusion if he's smart he
probably got someone else to write it
for him well he could have done is
taking a selfie and instead this is me
by Trace mother they need to trace him
because they need to find out like who
to give the cancer services and stuff -
well how they gonna say I agree to your
terms of we're gonna give you cancer
treatments and only less than the years
jail time so right back to us like how
they gonna return it back well he said
in the letter you have to announce it on
the nail on the news but what if he's
not watching TV that day you know I mean
Isis should get as widespread and people
in the world well he's dying - I'm
pretty sure he's not going anywhere
well worth the cops are like we don't
want your old ass anymore and [ __ ] you
like this is all the [ __ ] because of
this letter the FBI ended up reopening
the case to see like it's really is him
I want him just so someone could make a
movie out of this [ __ ] and in light make
a movie I i watch the one where they
escaped yeah but I want to watch the one
what
since afterwards anything yeah cuz
there's no rapper that's true that's
true and then no one knows what happened
if they died or if they survived or like
whatever so what if okay so this I could
be this can be like a ruse a ruse from
like this old man who just wants cancer
treatment oh and it's not a bit hard and
so he knows all the details what was his
original charge because Al Capone was
there and in like people that are
murderers and big time criminals that
was business trash you know or you can't
even be near society why would it
benefit the justice system to even get
him back in jail for one year so both of
the brothers were originally in there
because of the fact that they were bank
robbers and that they use a weapon once
which was a toy gun but they were
arrested and they both received 15 to 20
year sentences I wasn't too bad it's not
like they [ __ ] murdered the [ __ ] out
of someone but they family they
repeatedly kept trying to escape from
these facilities and that's why they
were transportable damn these big
achieved it mm-hmm yeah even from like
one of the hardest yeah I wonder how
they did it you could watch a movie on
it oh yeah they tell you how he did it
it was that movies specifically about
these guys oh it's all is it the one
with the rock wherever the lightning
strikes I don't know but there's a
there's al capone in it ooh it's pretty
cool they blew up some little things
that they made up and then they use that
as floaties yeah 1979 film the reason
they shut down Alcatraz because that's
just dope I never been there I think
it's I wish I did cuz my uncle used to
live up there so we used to visit all
the time but I never got to go we did
that tour it was really cool yeah mm-hmm
worth it isn't uh there's a elementary
school there isn't it what yeah they did
quite the islands begging us actually
have it's a big-ass islet oh that was
just like a rock and then the prison on
the note it is but the people that ran
the prison they had families I believe
that makes sense oh that's cool wait
they live there too mm-hmm it's just
easier for the community yes it's like a
military base it is it's like a military
base before a prison something cool Wow
but I don't know we'll never know this
is true or not I want to know like what
he did after escaping he's all hmm okay
so maybe I'll rob a little bit more in
Seattle not really working out and he
comes to Southern California and then he
becomes a surfing surfing instructor or
something oh I know I wonder what yeah
like what did he lose or the other guys
to whatever they end up doing with their
lives if they'd really did escape it and
where did they leave or like survive I
always wonder like would it be that hard
to live under a different identity like
you don't have a social security number
how do you get a job how do you get
family by a help maybe it was easier
back then no I I heard that it was
easier to get like Social Security and
whatever back then because people just
didn't have if they just didn't have it
they didn't have it they would just go
and get it
so they spent months planning they used
a homemade drill
fashioned from a broken vacuum cleaner
motor to loosen the air vents at the
back of their cells [ __ ]
they ended up like making a hole where
the vent was so this big [ __ ] so they
claimed through the vents or they went
through the vents they climbed up the
pipes and the plumbing to get to the
roof and then they finally split down
the smokestack to the ground below
from there they shoved off a makeshift
rafts made from more than 50 raincoats
Wow
that's all we know oh they also left
dummy heads made out of plaster paint
and human hair and in their cells these
are crazy don't say like if you want
like the world's best engineers look at
prisoners and people who want to get
high and they don't have a bomb or
anything smoke out of you know they're
so [ __ ] creative they should be
working for NASA yeah I do that's was
incredible yeah but then they'll
probably program the robots to steal or
something [ __ ] like a warden there Oh
sleep [ __ ] I'm not even mad I'm pretty
[ __ ] impressed that's actually
incredible good job at least they get
fresh ocean air well is breathing oh
yeah the freezing waters sharks
yes how far away from me is it from
from mainland it's pretty in the middle
of the bay you could see it but it's
it's pretty far swimming wine as [ __ ] I
bet they did this at night too so it's
even [ __ ] colder during June though
so at least 7 Cisco waters are cold as a
mother cold
yeah that's where big-ass fish are and
just [ __ ] sharks oh [ __ ] [ __ ] that
[ __ ] dude
I know people actually swim on the beam
yeah they're stupid that's why would
they do such a thing
I used to go to what's it called a
big-ass aquarium is doable any aquarium
that you've been to maybe not the one I
have been there an age again sucks so
San Diego recently I went there just for
like a day trip I went to this Birch
Aquarium place what the [ __ ] was that
yeah looks like I was at a [ __ ] Asian
restaurant that's how I was like cutoff
[ __ ] [ __ ] of this I paid $20 for this
[ __ ] are you kidding me Chinese
restaurants have good aquariums it's so
interesting though but you realize your
ethnicity because I just like delicious
delicious yeah I'm the same way when I
see cuz I see you like Bonita tuna all
out no more yeah there was like these
like little this tank would just all
mackerel yeah it's like I want to grill
you and put lemon and salt on you right
now aquarium in Okinawa is it the second
largest aquarium I saw a whale a shark
up close for the first time I almost
[ __ ] poop my pants
that shit's [ __ ] huge I seen a
sunfish mola the Monterey Bay cities
yeah so dumb but I love it we should do
it like when you're kids older we should
do a show right now when your kids about
the kids come on I went when I was
little I don't remember much I just
remember the Otters uh my parents took
us there probably like two or three
times it's pretty awesome yeah cuz I've
been wanting to do like a family trip to
like give somebody the Grand Canyon all
that stuff's really do and I'm gonna do
that for Isaac what did you try to sneak
in that TIFF moment inside why don't you
do that because just like it's more fun
with more people oh that's
you guys can come to I don't know but
the Isaac's gonna be like 25 why if you
want to wait for Tiger to come it's not
gonna take that long it's like a couple
years I think around six and on he'll
remember yeah because I went to the
moderating fool dude he's be like 70 80
you try to go the Monterey Bay equip you
up get your ass in the [ __ ] car so I
could carry you inside how do you say yo
somebody in Spanish yeah because the way
David said it sounded really awesome I
mean it's the name of it so we're not
gonna change though you'll submit this
that's how a Marriot body was conquered
she is Japanese is fun she was like oh
I'm going to use to meet day with my
friends my god she calls it that
you mean yes everything yeah no cemani
National Park she goes it's called y ou
know her her shits all [ __ ] up cuz she
knows four languages so it just all
sometimes it all mixes together I don't
know what she's saying
that's called it just send me back
[Music]